we had a in the comedy world there's a
comedian Ari Shaffir and he you know he
had some wild thoughts on the Kobe
situation and some people were not
excited about that I want to play this
video that Ari Shaffir put out you can
if you haven't already heard it and this
was after the plane the helicopter crash
homeward as always a lot of like hey
pain in the world and so he's a bunch of
terrible stories every once in a while
there's a good story good story comedown
guy who got away with rape got his today
Kobe Bryant is a God I'm here in
Charlotte the home of the team that
originally drafted him maybe wouldn't
break that chick in Denver if he had
been if it stayed a shower with the
Hornets anyway the point is it's people
it that didn't go over well I mean I'll
put that right there it just didn't go
over well with people Ari also had a
tweet Kobe Bryant died 23 years too late
today he got away with rape because all
the Hollywood liberals who attack comedy
enjoy rooting for the Lakers more than
they disliked rape Big Ups to the hero
who forgot to gas up his chopper I hate
the Lakers what a great day hashtag [ __ ]
the Lakers there's a lot to unpack I
think and all of that you know I mean I
personally I went through a gamut of
like thoughts and emotions but with it
just like a regular dude man like and
it's funny because the way I thought
yesterday about it and the way I thought
today about it have adjusted I mean at
first I was just like man this is this
crazy like is is he joking is he serious
[Music]
you know there were children too were
children that died and so you can't you
know it's just that's too much to joke
about it's too much you know I was like
it's
it's too much there was also part of me
that was you know that I I had the
thought to whenever you know when a lot
of people were you know really lamenting
Kobe right I was like yeah did he rape
someone you know that came into my head
I could never I couldn't remember
exactly how that had played out in the
court system and stuff
but here's a guy that was accused of
that in at net you know we went to court
and then there was a settlement so those
are just things that kind of popped into
my head you know and then once you I
learned that his daughters and you know
that there was more people involved his
daughter and other young people and just
I mean it just uh for me it landed in a
hole in and it's a whole different spot
now for Ari Shaffir I mean he's an edgy
comedian that's his whole thing you know
he's uh he is he's harsh he is vulgar at
times maybe
I mean I'm and I'm not you know I'm not
like denouncing Ari I don't believe in
this canceled culture stuff at first I
was just shocked I was like wow what is
he trying to get attention is he you
know is he the video it had like he has
like a little bit of a smirk in it so it
came if for sure was gonna make people
irate I mean it was just there was too
much he was doing it in front of a
picture of other basketball players in
Charlotte there's just so many elements
that make it bad or that make it tough
to digest let me say that especially on
a day when so many people when he was
just beloved by so many people and then
it's interesting because then today like
last night I'm looking at different
tweets like Michael Rapaport took took
re to the woodshed really he
he goes I want people to see who this
piece of [ __ ] is I think it's disgusting
Rapoport went in hard on the dude he
said meet comedian Ari Shaffir this is a
professional comedian hashtag Ari
Shaffir at Ari Shaffir he was not stoked
ari got also referred to as a white
supremacist their racist piece of [ __ ]
you know people went at him he I mean it
was funny how it was interesting it was
interesting to see online how the hatred
online just started to build and turn
over itself and how it got people called
Joe Rogan into it like just how it just
kind of became this some like an
avalanche like a hay bale that's
somebody pushed over a levee you know it
became this building thing this Manama
noble snowman and then today I'm like
well I mean if you it's tough because
you've you have to if you want to
believe in freedom of speech which we
have to have it then then some people
are just gonna say what they want to say
you know I don't know our he's intent on
this I don't know if he's trying to sell
tickets in Charlotte I don't know I
don't know I mean people also say this
is a character that he does where he
does a lot about like when people die
he'll make like a funny video or a funny
tweet or make a tweet trying to make
light of a situation under a certain
like dirty character that he has
honestly it's interesting as if already
walked into the room yesterday if he
walked in I'd have been like dude what
the [ __ ] what's going on and I think
that's how most people would have been
if he in human in human form would have
walked into the room after you had seen
the video and read this tweet but online
it's like this other thing you can be
you know people are like Santa I'm gonna
knock him out right when I see him at
the Comedy Store
people are saying black people go get
this guy
there was definitely a lot of black
racial hatred towards him and from
everybody I mean it was from all
directions and it wasn't just black for
sure but you know there was like so you
know black Twitter can be the Bob but
yeah I just thought it definitely it was
just it was some rough timing
it was definitely rough timing but that
had to be what he's going for
I mean that's what he's doing there's
some people that you know there's like
whatever that sign is the insult dog
member that guy the little dog the
puppet and then there's re the friend
the death wish Doberman you know I mean
he he wanted all the smoke and he got it
man he definitely got it so my I just
ended up thinking that if we're gonna
people can say what they want and they
should be able to say what they want and
the repercussions of it are Pete other
people are gonna react the way they want
to you can't say that people can't say
something even if you don't agree with
it I can't say oh he can't say that and
I don't think that Twitter or any you
know any of these platforms should be
able to say someone can't say something
the way you learn what works and what
doesn't is by trying things out now I
don't think that I mean I don't know if
this is him trying some I mean I'm not
I'm not saying any of that but I'm just
saying you have to still have that you
know now he know he knows how people
feel and that you know people get to
react the way they want to to certain
things that's what it's all about
but I just think it was interesting when
I thought to myself okay well he's
online saying this this stuff but if you
see him in person what I would probably
be a lot more human like how you know
I'm thinking I would be like Oh what do
what was going on man geez I think you
will freaking you know is it tough to
take a nap because
so many because your phone is just
burning with the hatred of so many
people towards you I guess that's my
thoughts on it you know you say what you
want and you can suffer the
repercussions of it or you can see how
people other people feel about it but to
say this guy screw then you just don't
go by it then don't buy a ticket if you
live you don't want to see him
now some people who's into the dark arts
and stuff they're gonna really thrive on
this they might buy a new kitten or
something name it already Shaffir I mean
I don't think Michael Rapaport is gonna
buy one but you know just like anybody
he can say what he wants to and then
people get to react to it and then
that's how you you get to say what you
want back so that's really my thoughts
on it I mean I just the part that scares
me is when they start saying that Oh
take this guy's a count away and take
this sort of thing like that just that
because that's never gonna help anything
people still have to be able to say what
they want that's how you learn you know
that's how you learn but man that was a
ballsy [ __ ] move huh it was just a
ballsy just like I don't know if I could
take all that heat online I don't know
if I could take all that heat thank you
guys for checking out this clip and if
you want to see another clip then you
can look at this clip or this clip
either one of these so did you pick one
or he's still just watching me do this
cuz it's alarming